country singers maren morris and cassidy
pope stood up for the queer community
over the weekend when the influencer
wife of country star jason aldean posted
a transphobic caption on her instagram
britney aldean captioned a makeup reveal
video i'd really like to thank my
parents for not changing my gender when
i went through my tomboy phase i love
this girly life husband jason commented
on the video thinking he's funny saying
lmao i'm glad they didn't too because
you and i wouldn't have worked out
while catching the transphobic caption
without tagging her the voice winner
cassidy pope tweeted you think celebs
with beauty brands would see the
positives in including lgbtq plus people
in their messaging but instead here we
are hearing someone compare their tomboy
phase to someone wanting to transition
real nice great point cassidy brittany
also shared a lengthy response tagging
cassidy on her instagram which in part
said advocating for the genital
mutilation of children under the
disguise of love and calling it gender
affirming care is one of the worst evils
and maren morris has entered the chat
marin replied to cassidy's tweet saying
it's so easy to like not be a scumbag
human sell your clippings and zip it
insurrection barbie
get her marin britney's friend
conservative candace owens decided to
jump in with her own opinion which
nobody asked for or needed replying to
maren's tweet saying it's easier to not
castrate your children but i guess
whatever helps sell bad records well we
all know the outspoken marin was not
going to take that she replied with a
tweet that said oh my god not you my
grammy is positively sobbing right now
also why do you always go to the
castration and pedophiles to try and
shut an argument down it's honestly
concerning and worth looking into
marin's husband ryan hurt also tweeted
in support of his wife saying scoring
quick points by picking on trans kids
isn't something that is brave at all and
i'm proud of marin for sticking up for
them badge of honor to have co engaged
in completely normal discourse too shut
up and sing only applies to those who
you disagree with out and proud
grammy-winning country star brandy
carlisle praised marin tweeting bravo at
maren morris it's when you selflessly
bear another's burden that you actually
reflect god's love
way to not tolerate disgusting behavior
it's tough but good to see this hidden
divide exposed in country music let your
little light shine and last night trans
activist and star of rupaul's drag race
season 14 carrie colby was asked about
britney's comments on the 2022 mtv video
music awards red carpet i mean honey you
can't fix stupid but you can show it how
stupid stupid is so that's pretty much
what i'm out here doing we are showing
ourselves that we're visible we're not
afraid we do exist and we have the right
to be there so
you know what the more we walk through
in positivity the more that we can make
negativity a little less negative you
know like
girl bye
hey thanks for watching et canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos